are you a fan of tom waits of course
uh tom waits he was younger had
his this is a song called martha
but there's a bunch of songs he's
written when he was young was like how
does a young man
have that like melancholy wisdom
the song martha is about
uh
an older man calling a woman he used to
love that she's not married and he's
married and they're having that
conversation they haven't spoken for 30
years and they realize that they're
still loved there and it could have been
a different life a different
world where they could have been
together and here's like a 23 year old
tom waits writing so beautifully about
something that's very uh i've had a lot
of people
like tell me how
real that
uh as an older person looking back at
that love that you had and realizing it
wasn't it was really it's still there
inklings of that love are still there i
think there's a um
when a young person writes a
sad song
they almost seem more willing to go to a
more hopeless place
because they have
they have a lot of someone's journey
ahead yeah and older artists tend to
want to look at the bright side of
things which which also i think comes
from the wisdom of aging it's a more
realistic position
so it's not uncommon
for younger people to write i think even
in the beatles you'll see like
they're very heavy lyrics
um
middle to late era beetles which is
still you know they're in their 20 you
know
early 20s i guess wow that's hard to
think about
so much accomplished unbelievable
and they they went through the full
journey from fun
to darkness
in a span of a few years
uh you mentioned lyrics um so you've
obviously produced
albums with incredible lyrics i think
you've mentioned that the interesting
characteristics of hip-hop of rap is
that you're
writing poetry to rhythm
versus writing poetry to
melody so that's like one way to think
about it yeah and i'm a fan i mean tom
waits leonard cohen i'm a fan of poetry
period
is there
something um about highlighting the
poetry of it the power of words as you
did with
with hurt
if uh like if i have to play it's one
uh a tom waits song
that's like
less than a minute long that i always go
back to it's one i really love it has
just a few lines
it's called i want you
and all it is is him saying i want you
[Music]
i want you
you you this is a 22 year old tom waits
you you
[Music]
all i want is you
give your stars above
sun on a brightest day
[Music]
giving you all my love
if only you would
[Music]
hums for 20 more seconds
beautiful it's so
so simple man that young man like lo and
but for people who don't know tom waits
you should uh definitely listen to him
and his voice sounds very different now
and it's interesting to see the
evolution of a human voice
the
the artist
over time because that's a young like
boy-like voice
hopeful
less clever less woody more simple that
simplicity is there and he's not i mean
that takes guts to be so simple i would
say lyrically
and uh musically
you